ray lahood chiot traduction relancer le
nom du décret qui entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui en italie pour relancer
l'économie transalpine fortement impacté
par la crise sanitaire
parmi les mesures une grande opération
de régularisation de sans-papiers et ce
jusqu'au 15 juillet une action limitée
aux travailleurs du secteur agricole et
à l'aide à domicile objectif faire face
à la pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans ces
deux domaines qui ont particulièrement
souffert de la fermeture des frontières
lors du confinement les habituels
travailleurs saisonniers n'ont pas pu se
rendre dans le pays provoquant ainsi une
sous production environ deux cent mille
clandestins pourraient obtenir des
papiers selon le ministère de
l'intérieur
on en parle avec matteo ghisalberti
rédacteur en chef du site d'informations
putsch médias bonjour matteo ghisalberti
merci de répondre à nos questions en
direct sur rtl france comment est
accueillie cet article sont 3 du décret
de relance sur la régularisation des
sans-papiers par l'opinion publique
italienne
bonjour ben il est accueilli de façon
très tiède de la part des beaucoup
d'associations de catégorie des 110 cas
par exemple des producteurs agricoles
parce qu'ils estiment qu' on avait la
possibilité d'appeler beaucoup
d'italiens beaucoup de chômeurs italiens
ou des migrants réguliers pour
travailler dans les champs plutôt que
allait régulariser des personnes qui
sont dans la clandestinité qui ou bien
qui déjà travaillé effectivement dans
les champs mais qui était en fait
victime de l'exploitation de ce qu'on
appelle en italie les capots rallye
c'est à dire
des t-shirts qui font travailler pendant
des heure de journée un fini
pratiquement les plus pauvres soit
parfois des italiens soient des
clandestins pour quelques euros et en
toute illégalité
donc la partie les représentations du
monde agricole mais en d'estimer que
cette mesure allait finalement favorisé
le travail au noir parce que on ne sait
pas si après la fin de cette validité de
dison de la régularisation des des
documents pour les personnes qui
pourront travailler dans ces tenues
agricole qui aura un retour dans le noir
un retour donc dans les mains de ce qui
se passe ces filières
mais au final n'est ce pas quand même un
juste retour des choses de régulariser
des gens qui ont potentiellement
continuer à travailler pendant le
confinement et qui ont maintenu à flot
l'économie italienne largement impacté
par la crise sanitaire beh à vrai dire
le problème c'est que à la différence de
ce qui se passe en france en italie on a
pas de mesure d'associer à vous en tout
cas beaucoup plus limitée par rapport à
celle française donc il y à vraiment de
personnes qui se retrouvent dans la
misère et qui ont besoin de travailler
pour gagner même
qu'en dire des salaires très bas mais en
tout cas des salaires pour maintenir de
famille naturellement cette mesure a été
introduite par la partie la plus de
gauche de gouvernement en particulier
par un ministre de l'agriculture qui
elle représente le parti de l'ancien
premier ministre matteo renzi donc vous
faites vous faites allusion intérêts
zabel à novara la mise de l'agriculture
qui a failli démissionner en tous les
cas elle a menacé de démissionner si une
ancienne représentante syndicale
le fait qu'elle ait menacé de
démissionner qu'est-ce que ça traduit au
sein de l'exécutif italien s'il ya des
fissures au côté de giuseppe côté le
chef du gouvernement italien
le gouvernement italien ne tiennent qu'à
un fil
c'est très très très instable ces
moments parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il y à
de petites tensions dans les paris les
forces qui soutient la majorité le
gouvernement risque de tomber
en plus en ce moment on a découvert
grâce à des quotidiens italiens que par
exemple les magistrats tout une partie
des gauches de la magistrature italienne
a soutenu des attaques contre l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur matteo salvini
notamment quand il avait empêché aux
navires des ong de d'arriver en italie
et donc on a vu que la magistrature est
faisait de la politique et faisait de la
politique de gauche et le parti
majoritaire qui actuellement au
gouvernement donc le parti démocrate
majoritaire de gauche avait soutenu
cette campagne est donc le gouvernement
est encore plus
on dira affaibli et il suffit que voilà
une petite composante comme celle du
parti de l'ancien min de l'ancien
premier ministre
matteo renzi menace de sortir du
gouvernement que tout le reste va
risquer d'être jean boulet revenir sur
ce sujet de la régularisation de
sans-papiers on parle de 200 milles sans
papiers qui peut qu'il pourrait être
donc régulariser ces prochains jours en
italie
on se souvient qu'il avait déjà eu un
tel dispositif en 2012 pour quelle
efficacité
c'est toujours difficile à établir
bien sûr il y a un problème de
régularisation de personnes qui dans les
faits habite déjà à l'italie le problème
de quel signal on donne aux filières de
passeurs ou en tout cas aux filières de
même qu'ils de la mafia qui exploite les
plus faibles italiens ou clandestins et
qui donc a vu nantes tout ce qui est
l'un des problèmes de l'italie donc la
corruption et le fait qu' on essaie
toujours de contourner certains règles
et qui rend pas contre l'existence a
déposé aux personnes inhumaines
merci matteo ghisalberti d'avoir répondu
à une question je rappelle que vous êtes
le rédacteur en chef du média puccia